[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
carson palmer former nfl quarterback
course won the heisman trophy at usc and
uh making his weekly appearance brought
to you by level select cbd
carson good morning what should we have
been looking for with jordan love
yesterday
well the the packers organization has a
massive decision to make as we all know
at the end of the season and that was
the worst case scenario i mean all
jordan had to do was go out and complete
20 of 32 passes for 250 yards and two
touchdowns unfortunately
they were inept on offense they couldn't
hardly move the ball he looked like a
rookie in his first opportunity to get
on the field he had no rhythm no timing
there's a couple balls that he threw to
devonta adams that devonte was the most
confused guy on the field it just
it was worst case scenario all he had to
do he didn't have to go out
you know and light it up like aaron did
in his first chance to play after brett
favre left you know aaron went out and
and put on a show he didn't have to do
that he just needed to go out and move
the ball and look somewhat successful
unfortunately it went the opposite
direction they couldn't move the ball
the packers have a massive decision to
make at the end of this year and now if
aaron comes back
you know right before next week's game
against seattle it was so bad on offense
you can't if aaron is available to play
he has to play to keep them in the
playoff hunt for that number one seed in
the nfc if they have to go with jordan
again it looks like they may not may not
be able to beat a russell wilson the
seahawk team
but also i was wondering that you knew
they were going to blitz
if you're matt leflore
and why not run the ball more or could
could the play calling have been smarter
for jordan love
you know
it's also on the floor lefleur was there
when they made that first round pick for
jordan love so it was only to coach
lefor's benefit for jordan to go out and
have success and move the ball so
um you know i would have assumed that
matt lafleur would have put jordan in
the most
uh advantageous situation possible give
him as much success as he can get him as
comfortable as he can by running the
football by throwing more screens
getting him some easier passes and when
they did run the football aaron jones
looked pretty good he had a couple nice
big runs but they just didn't stick to
it they kind of felt like kansas city
was going to hang 30 or 40 points on him
so they needed to throw the ball it was
a it was an odd game plan and really an
unsuccessful day for the the packers
organization yeah but i think the bigger
picture and nobody's going to focus on
this carson is kansas city
kansas city didn't look good against
green bay at home without aaron rodgers
kansas city hasn't looked good in a
month um
they're a team that we have given them a
long leash we keep saying they're going
to be fine they're going to be fine
they're going to be fine but now we're
going on a month long of saying
they're going to be fine they're going
to figure it out they have not figured
it out
there were opportunities to run the ball
where they just needed to be a little
more
consistent with the running game and and
they had some success early but they
just keep wanting that big splash play
that big long play to tyreek hill that
big long completion
to travis kelsey they're not getting him
kelsey
you know i you don't know what's going
on there were some dropped passes he was
jumping off sides left and right he
doesn't look like an established veteran
he doesn't look comfortable mahomes
doesn't look comfortable i think there's
definitely reason to be concerned in
kansas city but we're starting to see
defenses
almost look at a blueprint against
kansas city and it felt like denver's
defense did the same thing against
dallas we're going to play deep
we're going to make you do everything
underneath here and we're going to try
to put pressure on you
and it was very successful for denver
yesterday in one of the bigger surprises
how do you explain what happened to
dallas
yeah i think those two those two fourth
down calls on fourth and one were uh you
know were the first one mccarthy thinks
all right i'm gonna give it to zeke
ezekiel elliott and he'll get one yard
he's always done it throughout his
career sure enough he gets stuffed
denver's going the other way with the
ball
and then mccarthy said all right i'm
going to put it in my other best player
on my team's hands and backs hands on
fourth and one or fourth and two and he
throws an errant pass i mean it was kind
of one of those games where as a head
coach you're giving it to your two best
players putting it in their hands to
find a way to get a first down they
weren't able to do it shockingly nobody
expected after that von miller trade and
kind of the the down couple weeks that
denver's had over this last month nobody
thought that was going to happen and
denver just flat out outplayed dallas
from play one to the last play of the
game
how do you explain the bills going to
jacksonville
oh just turnovers i mean it was it was
you know it was tough to watch there
were some nice plays that that buffalo
was making but josh was just getting
careless with the ball he had a couple
fumbles he had a couple interceptions um
and and when you've got a desperate
hungry team like they are in
jacksonville they're just searching for
anything they'll take whatever they can
get if you continuously give them the
ball and turn the ball over it just goes
to show you you've got to protect the
football because some of the best teams
in the league can lose to one of the
worst teams in the league if they don't
protect the football and they didn't do
that but what's it like when you go out
on the field against an inferior
opponent
and you have to keep telling yourself
that we can't take them lightly
but players still team still to do take
the opposition lightly
yeah buffalo got off the bus yesterday
walking in the stadium knowing they had
more talent on their bus than the other
team did and they played like it they
looked flat
they had some silly mistakes like i said
josh was careless with the ball
um and jacksonville their key marquee
players
jacksonville's josh allen made plays he
had a he had a sack he had a fumble
recovery he had an interception
you saw trevor lawrence making some
really nice plays the five-star players
in jacksonville jacksonville played like
five-star players
the elite players in in buffalo did not
play like the five-star elite players
that they were i think
midway through the fourth quarter stefan
diggs had two or three catches i mean it
was just one of those days for for
buffalo they need to forget about that
they need to wash their hands of it they
need to learn from it and move on
talking to carson palmer former nfl vet
joining us courtesy of level select cbd
baker mayfield spread the wealth he had
14 completions to eight different
receivers they ran the football played
some pretty good defense here
are they better without odell beckham
with what they want to do offensively
i i think they are i mean when you have
a when you are a young quarterback like
baker is and you have this
almost an icon in odell beckham that's a
weight on your shoulders that you have
to carry that is something in the back
of your mind as you're calling the
play in the huddle and you're you're
scanning the huddle and you see odell's
eyes
you naturally know okay i gotta find a
way to get him the ball i gotta i gotta
keep him happy i gotta keep feeding him
even if the coverage doesn't dictate the
ball going to him i need to get the ball
in his hands but did you just through
this at cincinnati when you first got
there of keeping somebody happy
all the time i mean i had terrell owens
in one side of the huddle and chad ocho
cinco in the other and i knew
that both of those guys i mean
the receiver position you can feel um
you can feel non-existent if the ball
isn't in your hands if you're just
consistently running routes
and turning and watching and seeing the
ball go to other players you can feel
like you're never part of the game and
and certain players like odell like chad
ochocinco i knew from a mindset
position i knew i needed to get the ball
in chad's hands i knew t.o needed to
touch the ball at some point in the
first half probably the first quarter
that's the same thing with odell odell
needs he's a rhythm player once he gets
in a rhythm he gets harder and harder to
cover but he needs the ball in his hands
to get in that rhythm and you just
watching that game yesterday you just
felt like
this massive elephant was off of the
back of baker mayfield i mean he had so
much mental energy over the last two
years trying to think of ways to keep
him involved in the game plan and get
the ball in his hands and you just saw
them let it loose i mean they had big
play after big play i mean people's had
the 70 yard uh reception chubb had a 60
or 70 yard run you just kind of felt
watching that game that the best team on
the field without question
was cleveland browns and i think going
into that game i was thinking the best
team on that field that day was the
cincinnati bengals and they proved me
wrong
i got to put you in the hall of fame for
just putting up with chad ocho cinco and
terrell owens in the same huddle like
who was tougher
uh
i i loved it i mean it was constant
comedy and practice and there was some
highs and lows and ups and downs but but
that's the game but hearing those two
guys tell you while you're calling a
play that i'm open i'm open i'm like
dude we're calling a running play
we'll get you on the next one
but yeah i mean those those two uh those
two mouths and those two trash talkers
were a lot of fun to play with but but
how did you
did it get to the point where it it was
disruptive to the team
that they wanted the ball all the time
no b b and and the reason it wasn't was
because those two guys practiced as hard
as any other player on the field every
single day i mean t ho tio was a
workhorse chad would go from the number
one offense practicing against the
number two defense to when the number
two offense would go in he would sub
himself in to get extra reps against the
ones so
i mean when you have when you have some
guys that have those kind of egos and
those kind of personalities but they
show up to work and they work their butt
off every day in practice you let all
that other stuff go to the side because
they set the standard in practice when
when your best players and your biggest
egos work harder than everybody else
that's a good situation to be in would
you want odell beckham
i would because he's the kind of guy you
can throw a slant to and he can go 65
yards now he needs the right pieces
around him he needs the um the right
play caller the right head coach the
right
receiver coach i mean there's a lot that
goes into controlling and
being able to be successful with that
type of player on your team but from a
from an ability standpoint there aren't
many guys that can run the routes that
he can and make the plays that he can so
i would take him
we had ben roethlisberger on last week
he sounded relaxed like this is
everything's good don't know how much
longer he's going to play but
feels like he's in a good spot there
um
do you think like i don't know if ben is
still he had a good year last year which
people forget about but is he still a a
formidable weapon
in the nfl
well he's definitely lost some some
velocity on the ball he's lost some
pocket movement he's lost some agility
and ability to extend plays which which
is what his forte was i mean that was
what he was so great at
um
but he's an absolute he he's a winner i
mean he finds ways to win games and he
may not have it velocity wise he may not
have the deep ball that he used to have
but he's still good enough to win games
for you and they still are good enough
on defense that that defense can keep
their offense in games where it's close
enough where you just give ben one drive
he needs a field goal he's down by two
he needs a touchdown he's down by five
he's good enough to win a game at the
end of the game which at the end of the
day that's all you need in this league
um but there's no doubt i mean it's it's
the clock is ticking his body is
definitely looking like it's 38 years
old but he's still been ben
roethlisberger he's got super bowl
championships he's been in big games
he's been in that moment he's trying to
win one last one on his way out the door
i just don't know if they're good enough
offensively if the weapons he has around
him are good enough to get them one more
super bowl win i don't know who to trust
in the afc right now because i think the
titans have proven to be the best team
considering who they've defeated
i just don't know if people would buy
into them as
the super bowl favorite right now so who
would you say that's the team
that the team to beat the afc
yeah not not without not without um
i'm blanking on his name dr kendrick the
running back no not without derek henry
i mean
that game was an anomaly last night i
mean there were some weird things that
happened special teams wise before you
knew it they were up 21-3 um
you know adrian peterson is a great
option to have right now but he is not
derek henry that team is built upon
derrick henry's shoulder so um they
probably aren't the best i still think
even though that game was really really
ugly in uh in jacksonville yesterday i
still think buffalo is probably the
favorite they've got the best defense at
the end of the day that was a field goal
kicking fest they really
they defense did not lose the game
offensively they couldn't hold on to the
ball
but
you can you can see josh allen he is up
and down he when he is hot it is red hot
when he's cold he was he was stone cold
yesterday but they were still in the
game they still were just a field goal
away so um the afc is is funky no doubt
but i still think buffalo is the team to
beat the afc great to talk to you as
always carson we'll talk to you next
week
sounds good thanks dan that's carson
palmer weekly appearance during the nfl
season brought to you by our friends at
level select cbd
looking for next level relief
levelselectcbd.com